second inning no score harold ramirez
will lead it off for cleveland
line drive right field that same swing
you were talking about early in the
series
staying on the ball going to right field
he goes into second base second
inning in a row the indians have a lead
off goal he got
now you look at how high this pitch is
and he was able to get on top of it
i was hoping that thing hit off the wall
that's not even close to being a strike
but he gets on it
that's like an eddie rosario swing right
there
and i was hoping it hit that wall and it
kicked by him but it came right back to
him
that wall can be very tricky down there
down the corners
and it will open the floodgates
that's what you need a little blue ahmed
rosario a blooper down the line drives
home
harold ramirez one-nothing cleveland
here in the second
fought it off and it stays fair nothing
so lyric could do on the outfield
wow duffy's shaking his head going i
can't believe that's the first run he's
given up
in the first four innings this season
now your thumbs between that
quick you know how he quickens it up and
how it brings it yes
oh right back to him what a snare by
mackenzie
he just reached right back and snared it
to end the inning
[Music]
i look forward to seeing his brother bo
naylor he's 21 his
younger brother
see he's a catcher
in the cleveland indian system
left center field ben attendee dives and
makes the play
so with that down go the indians in
order in the fourth
oh alex gordon-esque
beautiful catch andrew
and there's a debate if his dad bought
that car
he went he went yes he did struck him
out to end the inning
well done my friend four k's from
mckenzie one-nothing tribe through four
his
flare to right inside the line has
driven in the game's only run he got
harold ramirez to the plate
he's the number seven hitter
and now he grounds one to deep short
nikki lopez plants his feet
and on two hops over to santana in time
what was it a hard smash one two
ow
hit that ball hard nikki lopez didn't
take an extra step to get some momentum
he said i'll just get rid of it quickly
excellent job there by santana he's
keeping his focus
2-2 and a live drive base hit into left
field so renee rivera
has a hit in his indians debut to keep
the inning alive here in the fifth
well they wanted to get it inside but he
did not get the fastball in there and
rivera took advantage of it
two out single
he goes the other way with his third hit
of the afternoon boy he is programmed
today
rivera stops at second and the indians
have some two out magic brewing here
that's been their calling card
yeah and then on sunday that'll be at
ten straight games and then they'll have
an off day monday before they play the
cubs for two
and it's out west
ground ball and it gets through come on
here comes renee rivera they're gonna
wave him home he's gonna score without a
throw and the indians lead us two to
nothing
jordan luplow with his sixth hit of the
year with a runner in scoring position
extends the tribe's lead nicely done two
strikes again
it's a little breaking ball down and he
finds the hole between
short and third so three consecutive
hits off duffy with
two outs six out of 16 for luplow with
runners in scoring position
pride fashion pride of boys private
points merce was pride and passenger
points
i don't know i'm done
you know why we're really off on monday
arch right a second
it's close he gets in there safely look
at fran mill oh yeah i had that all the
way speed demon
well that's a good move up man you're
the lead off hitter
and just barely got in so perfect man
you get yourself
90 feet closer to scoring arch when i
see that i think when mike napoli did
that
almost every time a ball got away to
ahmed rosario
left center field that's in the gap
that's gonna get down and go to the wall
reyes will score amends around second
he's digging for three
he's gonna go in standing with a two-out
rbi
triple and a three-nothing indians lead
ahmed rosario had had a tough series he
was overnight in the last game he played
he was over four with four strikeouts
first at matt today bloops went down the
right field line it drops it goes for an
rbi
single and maybe that was a good
indication it was going to be his day
well this is a really nice job of
staying in there after he started him
out down 0-2 with a couple of fastballs
got a change up to his liking
goes in with a stand-up triple his
second on the year
and then in the sixth inning after reyes
had walked he scored on a two out triple
to left center by him ed rosario
the pitch reyes swings drives one high
deep to left
gone over the bullpen
and the indians lead it four nothing
reyes with his eighth home run
a towering blast down the left field
line
and the indians continue to torture the
kansas city bullpen
with runs from the seventh inning on
oh boy that was a spinner that said hit
me and he did
nice swing he knew it and everybody else
in that dugout do it as well
he stays with his game plan gets a
double play ball and now the o2 is oh
baby
[Applause]
the broom squad goes into kansas city
and sweeps the royals out of first place
the indians take over the top spot in
the central
with their first ever four-game sweep of
the royals
in kansas city
gotta go back to 1960 huh holy smokes
i'll tell you what it was one heck of a
series for the indians
kansas city had high hopes but the
indians walked in there and what a road
trip